There are arguably two types of intelligence.
Fluid intelligence is your ability to
reason quickly and independently of your
past experiences. It relies on the ability
to hold attention and benefits from a strong
working memory. While it can be trained, fluid
intelligence is mainly determined by your genes.
Crystallized intelligence is your ability
to apply knowledge from prior learning
that was stored in your long term
memory. It increases with experience,
and is hence mostly formed by the environment.
To solve complex problems, both types
of intelligence need to work together.
To illustrate how fluid and crystallized
intelligence work, let us tell you the story
of Arthur, a fine young man, who wants to save a
young princess that was captured by an evil witch.
The witch promised to release
the princess only if Arthur
brings her a precious jewel from a secret tomb.
Arthur agrees, begins his quest, and comes
across a deep, dark forest that he must cross.
He navigates through the wilderness with a
compass and a map — using the intelligence
he crystallized when he spent lots
of time studying maps as a boy.
At the end of the forest Arthur
discovers the entrance to the tomb
and sees the prized jewel already
sparkling in the distance.
As he enters the tomb, he
steps on a pressure plate.
His crystallized intelligence tells him
that this is a mechanical trap. — something
he learned about earlier in life. He
stands still, and thinks of a solution.
Since he has never been in this situation before,
he cannot draw on past experience. Thankfully,
his fluid intelligence takes over and
allows him to make a new plan on the fly.
Drop the bag! It puts pressure
on the plate and you can grab the
jewel! — crystalized intelligence
takes note for future reference.
Arthur then gave the jewel to the witch, freed
the princess and brought her safely back home.
Suppose Arthur was an average child and we were
to plot the development of his intelligence over
90 years. His fluid intelligence would increase
sharply until his early twenties and then peak
and decline. His crystallized intelligence would
peak later and slowly decline at a higher age.
The psychologist Raymond Cattell coined the terms,
fluid and crystallized intelligence in 1963.
What are your thoughts?
Can you think of a time when you used your fluid
and when your crystalized intelligence ?
Share your thoughts in the comments below.
This and all other Sprouts' videos are
licensed under the Creative Commons.
That means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms, online courses or
to start projects - and
today, thousands already do!
To learn how it works and download this
video without Ads or background music,
checkout our website or
read the description below.
If you want to support our
mission and help change education
visit our Patreon - that's patreon.com/sprouts.